I'm really delighted to be able to start
today by introducing to Susan Brennan
who um knows about as much about the uh
uh computer images of the human face as
anybody and she's got lots of
interesting things to show
you okay I'm going to turn on my view
graph here hope you can see
it
o I'm going to talk to you today
primarily about a program that I wrote
called the caricature generator um I
define caricature as among other things
a graphical coding of facial features
that seeks paradoxically to be more like
a face than the face itself um
traditionally executed with a minimum of
lines I consider caricature a form of uh
semantic bandwidth compression that is
it um amplifies certain things important
to the identity of the face while
leaving out non-essential details which
I consider noise um the result when it
successful is an image that is a
distortion of reality but nevertheless
it appeals to the beholder's mental
model of what's unique about a
particular face um the goals of my work
in caricature have been to investigate
the activity of caricaturing as done by
human artists to um survey the studies
of face recognition by both human beings
and by machines to come up with a
Thrifty parameterized model of a human
face that can be derived somehow from a
digitized image to come up with an
algorithm for taking this representation
and distorting or transforming it into a
caricature of a human face and finally
to implement this as an interactive
process on a computer which I call the
caricature
generator um generating a caricature and
recognizing it both uh depend on having
a model of what is unique about a
particular face but my intent was not to
model the whole process of caricaturing
as done by a human artist but merely to
simulate one possibility for the
visualization process that goes on in
the Mind's Eye of the
caricaturist um I'd also like to make
this process of visualization and
Distortion available to the average
person who doesn't draw but who's just
as expert at remembering and identifying
human faces as our most human
beings this work started out as a
computer Graphics thesis at mit's
architecture machine group within a
DARPA sponsored teleconferencing project
strangely enough and um the most recent
version that I'll show you on the
videotape was done at the late Atari
Sunnyville research laboratory where at
one point they thought it would be a
neat product for computer video games or
something like that but um uh at the
moment I'm working with Jill rhs in the
pych department and we're doing a study
of people's responses to these images
which I'll mention more later and we're
going to be doing it on MacIntosh and
Pascal
probably
um
I'm going to talk a little bit about um
psychology and face recognition just for
some background for you a particular
human face is a visual pattern which
we're able to recognize and
differentiate from thousands of other
faces which are metrically very similar
and this this I find kind of amazing um
we in fact have a tendency to interpret
even any abstract configuration say
rocks trees you know things like that as
human faces if at all possible so I
think that this tendency to be able to
interpret an abstract pattern as a face
makes possible something like caricature
which is the you know reduction of of a
complicated image into just a few lines
and this process of abstraction is
really the beginning of caricature um
the psychological literature suggests
that there's a pretty complicated
interaction of both um peac meal and
spatial processing going on in face
recognition um I'm not going to go
through all of these but um for instance
when you present a face a photograph of
a face to to a subject upside down or in
photographic negative um the subject
cannot recognize the face even if it's a
very familiar face um and this is pretty
amazing even because um the amount of
information and the intensity array is
essentially the same as in a photograph
presented more conventionally
um any kind of strong unusual feature
such as a scar tends to mask the real
differentiating features of the face um
and that was another study done by gper
um young children tend toay pay
attention to superficial or transient
characteristics on the face like hats
facial hair things like that um and
ignore the um the spatial aspects of the
face and trying to identify the faces of
strangers and uh certainly we've all had
the experience of of seeing a friend
who's just shave off his beard and
saying something like have you lost
weight or something you know um so you
know we are very very sensitive to the
the spatial parts of the face but not
necessarily to the the temporary
transient parts
um I one of my favorite theories is that
a sort of calibration goes on when you
see a face within a population of people
for the first
time um for instance if you meet a lot
of people at once you'll often tend to
confuse the two people who have red hair
or the two people who have beards at
first um and there's a little bit of
evidence that um supports that for
instance um gulper found that uh people
have trouble recognizing people of an
unfamiliar race when they see them for
the first time but this goes away
immediately upon becoming more familiar
with the people or with the
race so as far as psychology goes I'm
sort of a nuo gibsonian I like his idea
here which says in observing a
caricature or a political cartoon one
often does not notice the lines as such
but only the information that they
convey about the distinctive features of
the person caricatured the caricature
may be a poor projection of his face but
good information about it the form of
the face is distorted but not the
essential features of the face so this
is the idea of formless invariance that
um somehow come through and that's what
doesn't change regardless of age you
know animation of the face facial
expression uh facial hair
Etc so in face-to-face communication
which is another one of my interests
given that that's where all of us
started um the face can be considered a
sort of a high resolution display um
people are quite at separating the
invariant structure of the face as per
Gibson um from the the other things that
happen in the face temporarily due to
emotion expression um speaking and and
things like that we can do this
regardless of viewing angle and
regardless of lighting and um one of the
interesting things is that Machine
Vision hasn't even come close to this
yet
um
now mention a couple of things about
Machine Vision oh wait let me show you
this first here's an example of an
invariant kind of thing this is bertran
Russell's face here's his photograph
right here here he is as a child here's
one particular character by David low
and here's one by um Al herfeld right
down here so there's just something
there that that is contained in all of
those images and that's what uh Gibson
would mean by say the invariance of this
particular
face okay um I've been interested in in
finding everything I can on say faces
and computer graphics and faces in image
processing so what I have here is kind
of a list of some references I'm not
going to go through all of them though
um most Machine Vision systems have been
concerned with coming up with systems
for automatically recognizing people for
automatic security systems for instance
or for um matching photographs of faces
with huge databases of subjects as per
law enforcement agencies so these have
been the two applications that have
driven uh face recognition by machine um
the first work that I was aware of was
done by bledo in the' 60s um and his was
for um um an automatic security system
application kind of thing um he worked
on a system which automatically analyzed
faces but it avoided the problem of
finding features on the face um he had
human operators locate 46 points on each
face in his population then he
calculated 22 ukian distances between
some of these points and stored that as
his representation computer um and then
he found that um in terms of recognition
testing with both human beings and
machines the machines were much more
successful at distinguishing the faces
within this population than the human
beings who were just using their natural
ability to recognize faces um now
Michael Kelly in 1970 um was able to
find features automatically what he did
was um he filtered faces to get kind of
rough Edge drawings actually he used
whole body portraits of people which
gave him even even more information and
he used his scheme for gold Direct Ed
picture processing in in other words he
knew where to look to find various
features um he was successful at um
Building A system that recognized a
small population of people 75% of the
time now my favorite work was done by
Canada in
1973 who had a kind of a clever scheme
for automatically finding features on
the face
um he took um stereo pairs or or several
portraits of um people and then filtered
them using a lassan to get a kind of an
representation and then he um put a
series of vertical horizontal and Radial
histograms over this to look for
different kinds of intensity Peaks and
patterns on the face so in other words
he'd put a histogram over the image and
he'd find the top of the head based on
where that was he'd throw another
histogram down in this area and move it
around until it found the characteristic
Peaks for the eyes which would be these
lines around here um between your edges
of your eyes and your nose and then
based on that he would look for the
mouth and the chin Etc this was a kind
of a clever scheme because if the the
program didn't find something it was
looking for it would back up a few steps
loosen loosen its constraints and then
start again it also applied um its
knowledge about the symmetry of the
human face so that if part of the face
was in Shadow say half the chin it would
know that if it found the other half of
the chin it would know to where to
expect to find the missing half and it
would put it there um so that's that's
as far as I know the most successful
attempt at finding features
automatically now I'd like to just
mention Harmon's work um Harmon took a
population of 2 to 56 white males and
and um using uh testing subjects and
having them look at these pictures tried
to find the most average one for
instance and this is Harmon's Mr average
down here in the corner um beware if you
look like that um but he did find that
uh I forget how many
um oh yeah he took 21 numerical
measurements on all these white nail
faces and found that those 21
measurements were enough to distinguish
among a population of 256 white males
without any facial hair so this is a
very similar looking
population and that's sort of a
well-known study that was in Scientific
American years ago
Etc okay now after looking at some of
the heuristics used for machine studies
of faces I looked at um the heuristics
of
artists
see um first I should say about the
machine studies um all of these have
been concerned with taking num numerical
measurements soft faces and none of them
have been used to regenerate an image of
a face for presentation to and man
manipulation by human beings okay so my
interest was not only to come up with a
representation I could store in the
computer but also come up with something
that was generative that could provide
an image for people to look at
okay
so now I'm going to talk a bit about the
heris stics of artists portrait artists
um anatomists and
cartoonists now Leonardo D Vinci and
Albert Doro were both fascinated by
extremes of beauty and ideals of
ugliness as well and they sketched many
variations on the human form as you're
probably all aware um I don't consider
these kinds of things caricatures per se
because by my definition a caricature
has to be a portrait of a specific
individual not just a type or stereotype
say okay but this this stuff is
interesting in that it was conscious of
some kind of Ideal or basis for
comparison for human human faces um
bonardo um told artists to pay attention
to all the principal variations in the
in the profile for instance he kind of
treated the face as a series of
Primitives and Drew pages and pages of
noses and hands and and mouths and
things like that for artists to look at
and he really tried to categorize them
in in a way that would take care of all
the variation of human whatever okay um
so this this is a real peac approach
okay on the other hand Albert dorer took
a different kind of approach
and he provided he kind of treated the
face more as a a bit map rather than
excuse me oh move it up
okay Dora treated the face more as a bit
map oh it is you're right let's turn
around
okay rather than a series of little
primitive objects and um he advocated
putting a a coordinate system over say
an ideal face which is this was one of
the ideals of his time which doesn't
look very average to me at this point
but was an an ideal of beauty back then
and then taking this and um transforming
this into an idiosyncratic face like one
of these down here okay this is more of
a say an anamorphic Distortion of the of
the whole of the whole
array
um now the idea of a caricature as a
transformation from something to
something else is not a new one for
Durer another person who used this idea
was um one of my favorite old French
caricaturist named Nam um charl philipon
and he was famous for being thrown into
prison for caricaturing his Sovereign
Louis Philipe as a pav or pear which
also means Fathead in French so this was
considered not a good thing to do so as
his defense he published this series of
drawings which kind of shows a
transformation starting with a realistic
drawing of the king and gradually moving
it into this fair this pair of Fathead
drawing and his argument was that not no
one of these stages in the
transformation was to convict him and
from what I hear he got released as a
result of this okay so this was this is
the first example I found of taking
reality and transforming it into a
caricature which I think is something
that um is what I do in my imagination
when I do a
caricature way somebody argues that they
don't really deserve a c on their
paper because a and a minus were very
close and a minus and the B
plus that's right okay and then another
person that I discovered was um Francis
gross's work which was bound up in the
early publications of hogar the analysis
of beauty which is an an book you can
find in the uh rare book sections of
some libraries and uh Francis gross
actually um published the idea that a
caricature of an individual face starts
with some kind of norm and it deviates
from this norm and his point was that a
a slight amount of deviation causes
delight and laughter and beholder as an
extreme amount of deviation inites
horror and so he's kind of trying to
show you this with the extreme profile
distortions okay now um portrait artists
suggest studying anatomical models of
the face to get an idea of what the
geometry of a face is and what you have
to work within um caricaturists
especially newspaper caricaturists
suggests that you keep a file of
photographs from which to work um so
that you know when you have to do a
photograph a caricature of a politician
you pull out your file and look at the
four pictures and then try and distill
what the um key features are and amplify
those um now from my experience I do
something similar to this
um I find that it's sometimes very very
difficult to draw a caricature of
someone if you're just sitting there
looking at them because the tendency is
to try to record too many details at
once um and then you get you end up with
a more realistic sketch as opposed to a
character so I find that I like to study
the subject or look at the photographs
and then look away and visualize in my
mind um what the face looks like and
then I actually see the face transform
itself into a caricature um now
unfortunately when you try and get this
Vision onto paper um the tendency is to
just capture one or two of the features
at once in successive drawings and I
find that this process of putting marks
down on paper actually um inhibits the
VIS visualization process that I've been
able to accomplish in my mind so
um this is an here's an example of that
for instance um this is a finished
caricature that I did um at the start of
our teleconferencing project he was one
of the participants in the project and
here's the first drawing that I did um
right here I'm just trying to get out
the kind of long nose and the bushy
eyebrows right here I'm trying to get
the eyes kind of rotated Inward and the
long upper lip and the expression a
little bit better and down here um this
is you know the finished character it
looks a lot more like him than either of
these and neither of these looks like
part of the transformation that I was
imagining okay
now
see I'm going to show you a quick little
videotape which is another attempt at
doing the same subject um so you'll also
see a photograph of this person so you
can judge whether that's a reasonable
caricature or not
um this was my first attempt to use a
computer to do caricaturing and I'm not
um doing it procedurally I'm doing it
using a collaging program that I wrote
so in other words I could put a grid
over a digitized face um in this case I
trace the face as well and then I
stretch and squash the faces according
to um various analytical judgments I
made about the metric of the face so in
five steps I created the caricature that
I'll show you right
here so this should be queued up um I
don't know if you can see maybe we'll
stick this down for just a
second there goes
M okay here's the target the caricature
I did by hand and here's the subject's
face and what I'm doing is I'm loading
an image that I just traced using a
simple little um computer paint program
it's not a very good image it's kind of
metrically distorted and here's the five
different steps I underwent lengthen the
whole face lengthen the head rotate the
eyes a little bit widen the mouth and
then distort the whole face so that the
top is wider and the bottom is more
narrow see if I can pause
this so you can sort of see it so my
contention is that this result is a
better representation of his face than
this result up here even though that is
more realistic quote unquote in that
it's closer to the actual photograph
okay this is something that I did when I
was trying to figure out what the her
istics of machine generated caricature
could be however this unfortunately
still doesn't accomplish what I wanted
to do because it's still a very peac
Mill approach to the face I'm just
taking little pieces of the image at
once and distorting them I found that
what I really wanted was a process that
would enable me to um exaggerate the
whole face all at once and in parallel
the same way I could in my imagination
so that's um what the caricature
generator was written to do okay end a
videotape for
now distortions like like
dur um no I wasn't distorting the whole
coordinate system at once I was just
taking one of those areas in the grid
like a postage stamp and just kind of
moving it and remapping it onto the um
the
array okay we look like we're still in
Focus
here okay so here's that again if you
want to take a closer look at it um
these are this is the result of the five
steps now just as a preview this is what
the caricature generator did with the
same subject and I'll explain how in a
few minutes um here is the line
representation that was more or less
Trace from a face and here is more
Distortion and more Distortion yet okay
and here it is with respect to a
different basis for
comparison okay so I will explain all of
these in a few minutes
here anyway the common hypothesis is
that um a character selects the
attributes of the face that make it
unique and then amplifies those things
um clearly it seems to be on the right
track to say she has a really long nose
make it even longer or his eyes are
closed together make them even closer
the problem though is in deciding how to
measure things you know what things are
you going to measure and what are you
going to compare them with um a couple
of of uh Studies have addressed this and
trying to find out what a set of
features would be to characterize most
caricatures um David Perkins from
Harvard studied caricatures of Richard
Nixon and found that there were
um he said four different features that
made a caricature of Nixon recognizable
so he did a series of drawings which um
either left out one of these key
features or replaced it with an
incorrect component and what he found
that was interesting is if you leave out
a key feature it can still be recognized
but if you replace it with a key uh with
a a conflicting component then the face
cannot be recognized as a caricature of
Nixon so up here we have the his
character of Nixon with the the little
hairline bays and the ski jump nose and
the boxy little chin and the jws and
those are what he thought were the four
features here we have it missing
everything it turns out and here we have
like various combinations which look
more and less like Nixon for
instance
okay now another study Nixon is a real
popular subject by the way because he's
such an easy Mark I found him easy to
draw as well um another study was done
by Goldman and Hogan and um they also
used Nixon and they looked at um
caricatures of Nixon done by a lot of
different cartoonists and they found
that the choice of what features to
distort was pretty much uniform over the
whole population of cartoonist what
differed enormously was the amount of
distortion applied to each drawing and
they concluded that this was a function
of political bias and
style okay but unfortunately no one has
come up with the generic set of features
for every face and um I think it's a
very difficult task for Machine Vision
or artificial intelligence and I'm not
about to to deal with that because I
don't really think there's much hope
that it'll happen I think the the featur
set differs depending on the context
depending on the beholder and depending
on the the individual face
itself so as a
result I my kind of approach
is to give up on the notion of um
predetermined features altogether um I'm
giving up on the notion of what a
traditional feature is for you know the
the English language doesn't even give
us a way to describe a face you know the
features such as noses eyes and mouths
just are not adequate synthesize any
kind of representation of a face even a
police identic um consists of lots of
noses mouths eyes Etc that appear on
plastic on pieces of plastic like like
these overheads what you do is you pick
one component from each um category then
you sandwich them all together and you
have a face but if you slide things
slightly from you know left to right or
something with respect to each other you
get an entirely different face so the
fact that they've tried to um represent
this in a component kind of way just
still doesn't even work
so here's one of my favorite quotes from
gomri it's not really the perception of
likeness for which we originally
programmed but the noticing of
unlikeness the departure from the norm
which stands out and sticks in the mind
um this is really um what my theory of
character is based on um
so let's
see so what I did with the caricature
generator was I came up with the most
Thrifty set of lines that I could think
of and I did this pretty much by trial
and error to represent a human face um I
based this on say uding edges material
changes like between hair and skin and
boundaries and I made it fairly
symmetrical just for the ease of of
storing this in my database and um
implicit in my Approach is the very
convenient notion that the relationship
between between two lines becomes a
feature when it differs from the
corresponding relationship between the
same two lines on another face which is
congruently structured so um if if
there's no significant difference then
then it just doesn't get distorted very
much if there is a great difference than
it
does
okay
so what I'm going to do is talk a little
bit about my implementation of the
caricature generator and hopefully this
will be all clear to you there were two
stages basically one was taking
digitized images and coming up with this
representation and the other one was
taking these representations figuring
out a way to compare them and then
making an interface that a user could
use to generate caricatures with in a
dynamic kind of
way
so let's see I'll start with the early
part of the process what we're doing
here is um we had a digitizer that
digitized faces in six bits of gray six
levels of gray and uh Gary Fitz had
built this digitizer he was my cooworker
at Atari we then proceeded to filter the
images on the left to get the ones on
the right using a Ian um we could vary
the size of the filter for instance and
we could vary the thresholding and we'd
end up with a one bit image which we
then kind of dumped onto a symbolics
machine um in a run length encoded
fashion so it didn't go too slowly
then let's see we we played around with
the Canada uh theory for finding
features that I mentioned earlier here's
an example of some of the histogram
results placed over the face so where
you have these kinds of Peaks um you can
find the edge of his glasses for
instance you can find the hairline in
the top of the head through these kinds
of Peaks and if you look at that peak in
conjunction with this pink Peak that's
where the tip the top of the head is for
instance so that's how that worked
unfortunately um the resolution of what
we could find based on the canata method
was not great enough to provide me with
a number of points that I wanted to
represent a face so while we tried to do
this in parallel with the rest of the
caricature generator we ended up uh
giving up as most people do with face
recognition and doing it by hand
okay so here's an example here's a
picture of Alan Kay which doesn't look
too much like him and here's the
representation that is in the computer
now what I did with this was I
determined what I wanted the
representation to be like so I made this
thing that looked like a rubber band
face which consisted of about say 150
points okay and these were stored as
objects so that each line had a name and
a number of points and then a list of
the points and um these were all
connected by an interpolating swine
program which happened to conveniently
live on the symbolics machine I use the
one that's there um and so this is the
actual
representation that we have right here
and I've kind of made the points into
big circles so that you can see
them so um this is a very
object-oriented representation for a
face so that um is a real convenient
thing to store and manipulate and
animate and I'll show you that
later now in the process when you
compare two faces um you essentially
take um each pair of points so you map
every point on one face onto every point
in the other face and you take each pair
of points and you figure out a distance
Vector okay then you take an amount of
exaggeration which the user supplies by
a scale such as this one and you
multiply the vector times that
exaggeration constant and then you add
the new exaggeration Vector back onto
the old face so as you can see there's a
continuous transformation here and you
can see some of the points there and see
exactly the direction that the
Distortion is going on in so what I'm
doing here is you could say that I
picked features in a sense by the
representation to begin with I've chosen
to represent some lines and not some
others however I'm not figuring out
which ratios of distances are the the
important ones I'm just basically taking
any differences and amplifying them over
the whole um face so that's the basis
behind the caricature
generator okay and here's just a little
picture of what happens if you go too
far um I originally put in constraints
that prevented eyes from floating above
eyebrows and things like that but then I
found that people using the system
really wanted that kind of control and
that part of the fun in using it was to
see how far you could go before it
became unrecognizable as that person and
then go a little farther and see how far
you could go before it wasn't a face
anymore so that's something that the
user wants to
do okay let's see I'm going to play a
videotape of the system now and and show
you what it looked like on symbolic
machine and I'll talk over this and we
can see this again afterwards if it went
by too fast it's about 5 minutes
long he here's our Len 2 the first
version was done on an older symbolics
machine right now you're just looking at
the two windows the bottom is the
control window and the top is the uh
caricaturing window and the database is
just kind of cycling through so you can
kind of see what a user would be
confronted with you can kind of pick any
two fa
to caricature
with okay so um originally let me just
pause this for a second originally I
thought that there had to be some kind
of really coherent Norm like the average
face of all human faces or the average
face that an artist had ever seen or
maybe the artist's own face or maybe
some ideal of beauty after Leonardo da
Vinci or Alber dor or Oscar schlimmer or
someone like that but I later found out
that just looking through a population
of faces and picking any two that looked
really different in just some kind of
subjective way was an adequate way to
come up with a good Norm for
caricaturing a face in fact it even
worked to pick men and women and and
compare them and sometimes that worked
quite well um one thing that I'm doing
right now I'm trying to test um say if
you have a population of faces and you
take the average of of that whole thing
which is easy to get with my program
just by averaging all of these
structures together um if that provides
a reasonable Norm for differentiating
all the faces in that population against
so
now I I picked um both famous and famous
faces and faces that were just of people
that I worked with um I wanted to have a
a good mix of different kinds of images
for people to recognize I digitize them
out of all kinds of things like
encyclopedias and little tiny pictures
out of Newsweek and things okay this is
Diane Feinstein and here I'm showing
just the rubber band face that goes over
that and I've done it previously I'm
just redrawing it
there and you can see that I'm not too
faithful with respect to the hairline
and things like that that's not really
an invariant feature of the face for
instance so you do a whole lot of poetic
license with respect to things like
hairlines what you do try to preserve
are the spatial dimensions of the face
for instance now you may have noticed
that some of these spaces have certain
lines on them and others don't um what
happens is that every face can have a
virtual mustache which isn't used unless
you're comparing it to say alen kay who
does have a mustache and then then that
line becomes part of the comparison
process this is fedon away and here's an
example of the structure um of points
that represents the face again this is
about 150 points or so and I've drawn
them big right there so you can see them
and they're just spined together using
that program again I've made the
hairline um calm down a bit so that it
won't affect the other hair lines when
it's compared them to them this is John
F Kennedy digitized out of the
encyclopedia britanica and as you can
see this line drawing really doesn't
look very much like and which holds
perfectly with my theory that line
drawings aren't really good
representation of faces unless they're
Amplified apped in some way okay so in
other words I would try and get a better
representation through the caricaturing
process than that and that's the actual
point structure that's stored so you can
store a whole lot of faces on a small
computer which is another reason Atari
was interested in the idea okay now I'm
picking a couple of people to caricature
using the mouse and they appear on this
screen which is um horizontal and this
window which is
horizontal and this bar down here
corresponds to kind of a linear
Distortion so if you pick a point right
under Kennedy you get the undistorted
original um line structure that was
entered for Kennedy if you pick a point
out on the side you get a distorted one
it's perfectly linear at this Distortion
so what I'm going to show you next is um
just some of the distortions as you go
out along the bar and back and
forth and likewise if you were to pick
one right under the comparison face you
would get that undistorted
face okay so we're making Kennedy half
again is different in steps as from the
norm as he already is and then back
again so you can see the
okay next I'm going to compare Kennedy
to a different subject or a different
Norm excuse me and as you can see the
same kinds of things about his face get
distorted but all the details are very
different his face is becoming wider his
hair is getting more bant his lips are
getting a little thicker his eyes are
getting baggier
Etc okay so sometimes it doesn't matter
what Norm you choose the general things
about the face are still there and they
get
Amplified
okay next we're doing
Nixon and this is a Leonardo da Vinci
anatomical drawing face that I got out
of an old textbook and we're making
Nixon look less like Leonardo's ideal
than he already
does and now we're going to compare him
to Alan K you'll notice that Nixon does
not end up with alen's mustache because
um there's a virtual mustache only what
happens is when you pass through that
point in between the two then the the
features of the of the person with a
mustache will start to predominate Le
Alman or Jeff alond it's leave alond
really this is Howard Cannon the head of
the symbolics graphics group yeah really
okay so those are three examples of
Nixon now we're going to do Fay down
away apparently and leave
Alman
um now this time I'm going to show you a
continuing no I guess I'm just going to
show you one side of the scale okay and
then we'll do a continuous
one
okay okay Dian
Feinstein okay so you can see the
difference between two different
Norms okay now you can't see the arrow
very well but there's this arrow down
here which shows you what state the face
on the above window is in at any given
moment and now we're moving back back
along we're on the in between one now
here we have Diane Feinstein and a
caricature of her with respect to F
dunway so it's a perfectly two-way
process um which makes it kind of easy
to
visualize so you can do a caricature of
any a with respect to B and vice versa
and then when you stop in between you
get the typical animation inbetweening
kind of thing okay here we have an
example of a man and a woman which works
pretty well that's the young Li tailor
before the double chin and
JFK I mean there's a funny thing that
happens in the middle it's almost like
you know a necer cube or something where
it kind of looks like both of them for a
minute you could call that their
offspring or
something okay that's it for this and
I'm just going to quickly play the end
of another vide tape to give you an
example of what you can do with a
Thrifty parameterized model of a
face should be queed
up okay this is similar type to that one
just let it go forward a bit
here hello everybody I've been waiting
for
you welcome to atire your
search Please Release Me let me know so
this is basically type and talk mode
anymore um you type at the keyboard
whatever you type is automatically
correlated with the uh position
Bo
Ro you come
back well enough of that anyway
um now one of the neat things about this
is using the same kind of approach to
caricaturing that I used you can also
make some generic um lip positions such
as you know pouts and snears and blinks
and all kinds of mouth positions and um
if you have that template generated then
it's easy to compare that I think we
want to turn the lights on here he's
indicating to us um it's it's very easy
to take the representation of the face
that you finished on the caricature
generator and then just run the the the
template um program on it and then you
can generate all kinds of cycles of
behavior for that face um including all
the lip positions so um in other words
you compare the closed mouth to an open
o kind of thing and then you figure out
what the open mouth would look like for
that face and then you generate all
those and and you save them away in a
bit map and then when you're ready to
animate um you've written a program to
autoc correlate it with any external
event including a you know a keyboard or
some program you've written and the
thing just starts going away on its own
which is kind of cute um you can also
enter in a kind of a dynamic range
Factor so once you've generated the lip
positions for a face you can add in kind
of a an enunciation coefficient so some
people might tend tend to enunciate and
other people might Mumble so you can add
this other dynamic range in the
animation so the whole thing is just
really easy to parameterize and control
um another thing we did um in the
teleconferencing realm for this kind of
stuff was we took the speech signal and
we processed it in real time we filtered
it in 10 frequency bands and we found
that we could get the first two formats
or energy concentrations of speech out
of that information and map those onto
vowel sounds so the result was we had
kind of an automatic system where you
could talk into a microphone or send in
any kind of you know recorded voice and
have the system in real time autoc
correlate the lip positions and talk at
you so um if you if you look at it that
way you could you know very easily
animate a face for Saturday morning
cartoons or whatever or you could use
this as your teleconferencing
representation if you didn't want to
send your real face okay so I think I'm
going to stop here for a moment and um
afterwards I'll show you some examples
of the teleconferencing framework which
um kind of gave birth to this craziness
and also some other examples of ways to
distort faces that um cohorts of mine
have done at MIT and
Atari thanks very
much
yeah okay have a
hand yeah um yeah as as she mentioned
she has she has more goodies to show and
there's just too too much to put into uh
into one class hour but after class
we'll we'll be able to look at some of
the other tapes you also showed me this
uh U stereo thing in here everybody take
a look at this before you leave too and
so on can I have my uh jump
now uh okay so of course the main
purpose of uh my scheduling this for
today is that is to remind you that
there are 28 days between now and the
day that your project number five is due
uh and uh if that's 28 and Counting uh
and uh and problem five as you remember
is uh to do a self-portrait um subtitled
how to show the world that computer
scientists aren't entirely
nerds um we uh and I well I have just a
few things to show you and then and then
uh and then Dave krigman will will
demonstrate the uh the equipment that
he's that that we have here uh that you
could use to make images digitize images
and uh so I wanted
um I'll show you a few things um also um
I sent for a report hasn't come in yet
from by Brad McCormick uh of IBM uh but
I like the abstract uh because it it
demonstrates something that a lot of
people here might might feel it says uh
uh it the title of his report is a
10-page report that should come in very
soon called envelope art an example of
computer facilitated creation and it
says uh uh through examination of a case
history to shown how computers can
facilitate serious artistic Explorations
by persons who otherwise would be
frustrated in such Endeavor by lack of
the manual craft skills that are
prerequisite to Artistic Creation in
traditional media and uh this is uh this
is uh uh in a way the way I feel uh that
by using my programming to supplement
one of my other um uh defects I can do
things that otherwise I that I couldn't
otherwise do now um as you uh
uh as you saw in the in Susan's U
remarks the uh uh once we have something
in in a computer then we can what what
can we take advantage of well what are
computers good at um and uh and and
Distortion manipulation of parameters is
of course one of the one of the things
other things is that uh uh is is
repetition you can make uh you can make
something that repeats many times uh uh
where a person by hand would find it
much too tedious to do uh then there are
things like fractals where you have self
similarity and uh you can imagine
various kind of Transformations like
that and uh now if if some of you would
like to to um U look at resources in the
library that might help you uh preparing
for for problem uh problem five uh I I I
got two uh that I can recommend that are
in our math computer science Library uh
the first is called artist in computer
this came out in 1976 and it's a it's a
it's about 25 U
uh chapters each one takes a different
art like Ben laosi and he and they they
they talk to him or he writes what what
he thinks about uh his connections
between art and computer and the person
and Ruth uh believe it uh just uh went
around and saw what everybody was doing
with computers nine years ago um the uh
the other book is is another um it's
called visual art mathematics and
computers uh these two books um uh you
can look at them after before I take
them back to the library today and then
they'll be in the math Library this
again is a a a collection of articles
that that had to do with the subject of
of the I guess interface is the right
word to use with uh with caricatures and
and visual images uh in fact the cover
on on this book um isn't is a
self-portrait of um uh Dwayne poika uh
who works who was at
Utah uh at at at this time and uh so
South portrait there a key words here
now how does how do you go down suppose
somebody tells you um um go and do
something creative what's a good uh
what's a good way to uh to if you if
you're not feeling very creative on a
certain Thursday what uh what's a good
what's a what's a a stimulating way to
do it well I don't know um if there's a
real recipe to this but I know what I
did when I was a uh when I was a student
I had a collection of Mad magazines that
I would just just use whenever I wanted
to take my to to to jog my mind into
something in out of the normal ruts uh
now that was 25 years ago Mad Magazine
might not have the same character
anymore but uh but the the uh the exact
name of the magazine isn't important but
the technique I think was was helpful if
I had to write a a term paper for
history project or something like or
some kind of a you know English uh essay
or whatever I would just browse through
these Mad magazines about 20 minutes I
would get some idea that that wouldn't
have come to me otherwise um now uh
similarly I think by looking at books
like this and by seeing like
presentation that we have here today uh
these some something might uh might jog
your mind into something saying oh yeah
hey that would be interesting to pursue
uh a new slant on things because of the
the total popul the the the total number
of things that can be done between
computers and images is is so immense
that only you less than a small fraction
1% has ever been thought of so far um
but uh how do you think of new ones well
I think some kind of uh ways to free up
your mind from old things or or to just
study a lot of uh a lot of uh you Lo
overload your your input mechanism and
then all of a sudden something will
resonate with with your with your
particular senses um I brought a few a
few things here that um like remember uh
Professor k
gave a lecture and I and I and I took uh
his course as I told you and I wanted to
show you some of the things from that
course just to give an idea as
to as to some
uhu now first of all uh I'll show you
something where I just had uh I just
used a computer to generate instructions
that I could do in another medium um
this is a uh well you you probably won't
be able to get this on the TV it's too
bad but this is a uh uh something that I
did I just was interested in in color um
I U I had red and blue magic marker and
I wanted to see how the eye mixes red
and blue together if you take red and
blue of the same Darkness uh when do
they become purple and my original
hypothesis was that if uh uh if you if
you if you had a random pattern of dots
you choose randomly between red and blue
then the eye would make purple out of
that but if you took a very regular
pattern like a checkerboard red blue red
blue red blue then the eye would uh say
that look that uh looks like a
checkerboard well it was exactly the
opposite what happened now in this in
this diagram um the uh uh I generated
random random bits uh and and the the
lines at a constant well the slope is
about one six or something here but
lines at a constant slope is where the
probability of changing from a
checkerboard pattern was zero and then
here the next one is where the
probability was one and I and I and so
for each point I started with a
checkerboard and then with probability p
I change it uh from uh from red to blue
or blue to red and uh with probability p
is 1/2 then you get a random pattern uh
uh in between and then and then all the
all the degrees in between and so you
can you can uh it's until you get up
within a half an inch of there you can't
even believe that the red uh dots are
the same color as the red dots in the
random part cuz the eye ties them
together so so well into purple it
really changes the color of these dots
if you come and look at this uh closer
you have to get real close to see that I
didn't really use a different color
magic marker when I got to the other
ones but the main point of this was just
to to uh uh illustrate that you can have
a computer generate something that you
that then by hand uh you can put into
another form but by hand you could but
the computer programming was still
somehow an an essential part of the of
the of the idea this was another thing I
did for for his course where I just
generated the position of I forget what
the project was to be but it was uh I
the the position of these particular of
these particular dots was was decided by
a random number generator on a computer
with certain with certain density
function for the X and Y coordinates and
then I and then I had to some of them
were flipped or something I I so I just
had the computer generate uh
um uh uh input that I could then put
into another form now the the uh that
that course uh we were supposed to do 18
projects during the quarter and uh this
was the final project that I that I did
and I wanted to show it to you now
because Box's 300th birthday is coming
up next month and so my idea was to take
um was that uh uh if I that that I
wanted to to give B's face uh in terms
of his music and that the lines in a
musical score would probably Bend enough
that you would be able to to imagine the
Contours of of his face well in order to
make this this painting by hand
uh I needed a grid to to give me the
Distortion and so I prepared a grid and
uh this is the grid that I used
underneath that in order to get the in
order to get the face well it turned out
that the grid was much more exciting
than the final project and so and so
everybody in the in in K's class liked
this one much better than the than the
than what I had really been aiming for
in in the whole thing but in but U This
was um uh uh I had almost no equipment
in order to get this threedimensional
image in the in the machine um and my my
hidden line elimination algorithm was
was not very good um I just took a very
simple approach that I that once I had
little uh uh quadrilaterals for each
part of the face uh I I would uh I would
calculate the quadrilateral in three
dimensions and and and and and project
it uh onto two dimensions in order to
get this image but then I would look at
the normal to the curve and if the
normal was was facing towards the uh uh
towards towards the viewer Then I then I
actually uh uh plotted that
quadrilateral if it was facing the other
half plane I didn't plot it well here
this this must be a curl in the back of
his head somewhere where where where
momentarily uh uh shown through and
there's uh funny things going on over
here but anyway uh uh this the uh uh
this shows an example of uh uh where of
uh uh computer image that uh probably
was in the back of my mind when I when I
said problem five because I remember
enjoying working on this project very
much um it's quite a good learning
experience so what what I actually did I
I had a statue of BX that I bought at
the music store and then I I took
measurements at about 15 levels on the
Statue um and uh and then I so I had
corresponding points at 15 levels uh
which I could then interpolate by by
splines uh uh to get the to get
different cross-sections uh in in in two
different way okay
now um there's so so many things you can
do with with with uh images once you
have them in a machine and um I guess I
can show you U uh this
uh next um let's see okay these won't
show up too well but we did some needle
point uh based on uh this is my wife's
face where we where we reduced it to
three colors afterwards um and uh an
algorithm then for going from from U
many bits to U uh like we had we had uh
256 levels of gray and then to reduce
that to three by some by some filtering
algorithm this is another uh another
thing we we tried two different ways of
of um of of reducing the all the data
into three and you can you can look at
these later on uh um the
um uh the uh U it's based on a nice
method by Bob Floyd uh and Lou Steinberg
where they goes something like this you
start out with uh with with a lot of
numbers of in each uh Square element
that's called a pixel of your picture
you got a number between zero and one
now you've got to now you've got to
convert that into a smaller uh into a
smaller set of values um uh like uh
either Z one for example or in this case
we had 02 and one when we went to three
colors so so uh you make an error uh um
and and uh the Floyd Steinberg method
was something like this you you you
start at uh one part say upper left
corner and you you you round that to the
nearest nearest Value they had you had
for example suppose it was 7 and so
you'd round that to one let's say we're
making a twole image so 7 goes to one
but you've made an error of 3/10 so he
distributes that error of 3/10 by adding
it to the the three neighboring pixels
increasing their values by 3/10 um in
certain okay in certain proportion then
uh uh then he goes on and repeats the
algorithm now uh we found that uh if we
if we uh uh if if you do that without
without losing any of the eror at all
then uh then then glitches occur but uh
but you can improve the algorithm
by by having a damping effect instead of
instead of putting the air all 310 of it
adding it to the neighbors just add
maybe 95% of that uh to the neighbors
and then uh and then uh it won't have an
influence that might somehow add
together and uh and affect the bottom
pixel of the picture by very much um and
uh this this meant that you got an image
that was much more where the regions are
much more sharply defined uh than the uh
than this one where the where on the
average it's it's closer but there's a
little fleux of purple in the midst of
the brown here um and so so there's a
parameter that you can twidle as to how
much damping uh you want to do when you
when you apply that that kind of method
uh I can um so now once you have images
uh you can also um uh combine with with
typography and um I guess
um uh uh well let's see I'm supposed to
uh wait for a moment for them to change
tapes so I'm trying to figure out how to
time this here's an example of
typography uh these are
um this is a little biography of Picasso
and then of course uh you can use the
you can choose different type Styles
based on the uh on some on an image
that's already been converted to say
which type to use in each part of the
each part of the image um even if you
have an image and and you and you uh uh
convert it to zeros and ones and you
types set it as zeros and ones um It
looks interesting in fact the ones turn
out to be a lot lighter than the than
the zeros
here um this needle point is something
that's been going on for a long time I'm
I'm uh sometimes at faculty meetings I
take this with me and I still haven't
finished it but this is my son's face uh
about 6 years ago and we digitized it
and someday I hope to finish it but this
shows uh the results of Floyd's
algorithm applied to uh applied to his
face and we're doing this for all the
chairs in our dining room but by the
time uh we finish the chairs the kids
will have gotten married and maybe had
their families of their own okay um now
um so so finally the the uh manapon
system that uh I've uh uh that I've got
here you could read the manual that just
came out if you if you wanted to make a
special font specifically for the
occasion that's easy for us to do we can
typ set with your own you can make three
or four characters that might be enough
for you and you can and you can easily
get those onto the uh onto the printers
in Jack Hall and typ Set uh uh uh
illustrations that
way um many other possibilities of
course are are there so now we're going
to take a little break and then uh and
then uh uh Dave will will show how to
use the how to get images into a
machine
okay I guess now for the more mundane
end of things uh I guess you'll all want
to get uh images into the computer
somehow and so we've set up a little
system uh in the Next Room over uh I
think it's a12 you've all gotten the
hand out I believe and that explains it
it's all very simple to do there's a VI
a either I think it's a CCD camera maybe
a moss camera and we can take the video
signal and digitize it into an image
which is stores 250 6 by 256 gray levels
and each of those gray levels is up to
is 256 levels
so uh there's a good bit of data that
you'll be taking in and just for our own
economy be careful of uh keeping too
many images around because you'll clog
up a lot of disc space with it that's a
early warning on that
um the camera and monitor and the
computer will be set up in the next room
like I said it's a big blue box turn it
on by turning the on switches on three
of them
and
uh when you set up the C the camera it
all should be set up uh you'll just have
to adjust the focus and get bring
whatever props you want in if you want
props or whatever uh however you want to
do that uh the system to run
it it's uh running on a
sun a strip down Sun system and so we're
not running on the V kernel which you
see most of the sun systems running
around campus so what you have to do is
boot in a program and it's in the uh in
that handout about how to do
that
oops and uh I've created an account on
local machine here coyote
and cs204 is the name of it and the
program is called
cs24 I'll tell you the password after
class
whoops
I guess we'll keep the account around
for a couple weeks
um or a little bit longer it' be nice if
people would come in and I guess do this
within the next week or so just because
the equipment for your own sake the
equipment is going to start moving
around after a little while because we
do use it for the research here use it
while it works yeah and uh it's all
sitting on a 3 megabit ethernet and it's
very
flaky uh so there could be a the longer
you weigh the less chance there is of it
working and the same with the software
because as soon as somebody changes
something else it's going to probably
all die uh anyway but be that as it may
hopefully it'll all work uh after you
load in this program as in the
instructions uh type in question mark
will give the list of commands you can
display the direct video which is what
you're seeing there wave your hand or
something you're seeing
it and we can grab the image and that's
the resolution that you're getting right
now um if you start moving that's not
going to move and that can be saved on
uh locally on
coyote and to do that there's a symol
command s which will save it um you
might want to go through that iterate
over that a few times to get your proper
image and adjust the focus and whatever
else you'd like to do how it work on
photographing
photographs um we've used it to
photograph
slides that worked out just fine we were
using that for work here photographs of
Road scenes uh the resolution is is high
here is fairly High 256 x 256 so um you
might want to change lenses and there
are other lenses available if you ask
somebody around here they could show you
where the other lenses are if you want a
more wide angle or none of them are zoom
lenses but telephoto changing the focal
length
um and you might you might want to play
with the lighting I'm not sure how that
would work out you but you can give it a
try it should should work
fine um so this will just prompt you for
the file that you want to store it in
and you know your name or whatever
you're all going to be sharing the same
account so make it fairly unique
whatever your name plus a number or
something if you're going to do more
than one and
uh it'll then prompt you for the machine
and it's
coyote and username is
cs204 password will be I guess revealed
later um and it takes about 10 seconds
to save it's doing that right
now uh the file itself is
stored in a sort of mixture of styles
the first eight characters are the f are
the size of the image which is 256 space
256 and if you CED it out you'd see the
uh you see those letters following that
is uh more condensed form for the gray
levels each character represents the
gray level in binary so if you just
reading the character if you're using
Pascal using or would give you the
number um or just get car in in uh in C
or whatever language you're going to be
using it in uh when you the files then
can be transferred over to whatever
machine you're all using
explore uh whichever machine it is and
make sure when you FTP the file over
that you use it in binary mode because
it's stored as full Lake
bits um so that's that was as long as it
took to save uh should be fairly easy to
use like I said you can redisplay images
too if you want to make sure it's there
there's a way of putting it back on the
screen typing question mark will show
you the commands and I have a another
program around which this one's got all
the bugs cleaned out and it look it's a
pretty fairly Clean Program there's
another one which will do some uh run
some some filters over the images which
may be interesting uh at least it is run
a lot faster you won't have to rewrite
the code if you want to try that um does
some real simple Edge detection by
running a a convolution over the the
image spatial spatial convolution now if
you save twice the same phone
it it it destroys the old file right so
that's a way to
economize yeah you can always log into
the I'll log into that account and
remove files later on if it's a Unix uh
Unix
system
right let's get a picture of uh Susan or
Ramsey or
somebody whatam
hows
okay yeah one thing you'll notice yeah
um you want to tighten the aperture a
little bit on on front one yeah the the
camera doesn't have all that much
dynamic range so you're going to have to
keep it away from Bright Lights any
bright lights will start uh will really
saturate it and will cause the bloomings
all ugliness you'll see there and if you
get real real sharp patterns like the
background from a distance she'll get
aliasing yeah and the camera but
um
just things about focusing and stuff
like
that that's great oh hold
it
start feeling conspicuous you start
noticing what's wrong with your
face disturbing there you
are like I said you might want to go
through a lot of iterations on
that so that's how see how close he is
to it so that's the idea
that now now put your finger up in the
so so they SE the
Distortion the uh there's two knobs on
the lens the that's the aperture and
that's a
focus in general uh pictures won't look
so distorted if you use a longer focal
length lens look a little bit flatter
and if you use a wide angle lens your
noses start growing and and such
so which might be nice in some
ways
lens there's just G grabs a frame um s
to save L to load when
in there's a we'll load a file in right
with an
image there's another um program
I guess I could give you the the path
name on it um I don't know if people
would want to play with it or not this
would allow you to distort images a
little bit just using the near filters
which will just change the pixel values
it won't do any of the nice spatial
distortions that would happen in
character CHS but uh and actually we can
store really up to a 512 x 512 image but
being LLY about dis space I've limited
y'all on that um this this guy runs
really fast which
is why it's
uh kind of nice that's uh those are some
Edge representations using Robert's
cross which is fairly well-known uh Edge
operator an old one um basically just
accentuates the high frequency
components in the image um there's a
couple of these around here um another
thing that you might want to do is lower
down the number of pixels rather than
taking the full 256x
256 uh it's you can see these images
that only have 16x
pixels of the famous ones of Lincoln and
when you look at it and start squinting
your eyes you start really seeing that
it is Lincoln uh even though the amount
of information there is very small so it
doesn't take much to recognize people
and they say most of the information is
in middle middle frequency bands but you
can confirm that more than I
know and this is just a different filter
which is a little bit uglier uh not
properly normalized but again you might
want to might want to play with
these
um some other things that that's a
hierarchy of images that's been reduced
by a factor of eight and even down to
uh I guess at 64x 64 you can really see
what the the person is and you can go
down another one or two factors and you
can do why is it so fast uh it's using
some highp speed boards that do it yeah
they the board can do about 20 uh
million instruction well not
instructions but mathematical operations
a
second uh and a lot of the stuff up
there is garbage that's temporary things
that are created along the
way um but again some of that might be
useful and it's located and if you're
interested it's located in the directory
slm Mobi SL main
slmi uh it'll go into the
hand okay all right I'll give it to you
yeah so that's I think that's pretty
much the capabilities there's some other
filters
around which might be of
interest I
guess and uh they do interesting things
and none of this is documented
so this was a test program to test out
my my software um but it runs and and
works and you just have to play with it
for a little
while so I guess
enjoy
than okay okay thanks uh we got this on
yeah okay thanks a lot Dave that was uh
uh and so now we'll have a little uh
after class session to look at these
things up closer uh while he's here ask
uh ask last minute questions and uh
maybe even take a take a trip across the
hall to see the blue box and uh it's all
in know it's blue glory and so on um and
uh and I guess the only thing is uh it's
now um 27.9 days until the uh until the
final class uh okay
uh that's all for today
then